can you say if you want Ukraine or
Russia to win this war
I want everybody to stop dying yes
and I'll have that done
you need the power of the presidency to
do it but you won't say that you want
Ukraine to win oh God
I want Europe to put up more money
because they're in for 20 billion we're
in for 170 and they should answer and
they should equalize they have plenty of
money they should equalize I got with
NATO she said I sat down I got them to
put up hundreds of billions of dollars
under Obama and Bush and all of these
other presidents that's why they're able
to help them fight the war because of
the money I got but I want Europeans I
want Europe to put up more money because
they're laughing at us they think we're
a bunch of jerks we're spending 170
billion dollars for far away land and
they're right next door to that land
and they're in for 20.